in today's Aid on your side making
Furniture safer for families with little
kids one of the many goals of the
consumer product safety commission
tonight a look at what's being done to
increase safety and what part you need
to do
pick out all your jammies these videos
are tough to watch
[Music]
those go in the very top but that's the
point part of the consumer product
safety commission's Anchor It Campaign
which shows real footage of kids and
falling Furniture which could have been
fatal
[Music]
God
the cpsc began this awareness in 2015
working with families who experience
these frightening incidents to help
others avoid the dangers of falling
furniture and TVs it can only take a
second for a toddler to try to reach
something try to climb on a piece of
furniture and and tragedy strikes the
cpsc revealed its annual tip over report
this month and there is good news the
incidence of uh injury and death from
tip overs are going down but still
Pamela spring says between 2019 and 2021
there were nearly 20 000 ER visits in
the U.S from people injured during a tip
over last year the organization approved
a new safety standard mandating new
testing requirements for dressers this
is great news for consumers they can
they can be assured that any product any
furniture that they purchase after May
24th will be tested rigorously for
safety they there will be hang tags and
labeling to indicate such
and she has we as parents need to do our
part most of the furniture you buy comes
with an anchoring kit the brackets and a
tie to Anchor the heavy dresser drawer
TV or bookcase but if it doesn't head to
the local hardware store for more tips
you can also go to anchorit.gov